so public health officials were starting
to worry about
this about six weeks ago and we worried
we were likely about a month away
around mid-march and it's apparently
happening we are now seeing a slowdown
in vaccinations
not because of the temporary pause on
the johnson johnson vaccine expected to
resume
very soon not because of the lack of
vaccine supply
not because of a lack of appointments or
a lack of vaccinators as joe biden likes
to say
but because supply is starting to exceed
demand for the vaccine
in some of the more anti-vaccine
strongholds by which i mean
mostly in 2021 are republican areas
where
43 percent of the country's republicans
said at uh last week's polling date
they do not plan nor are they interested
in getting the coronavirus vaccine
all over the country we are hearing
about
vaccine vaccination centers with wide
open appointments
even simply walk in people were telling
me in mississippi it was just come and
walk in
in massachusetts it was just simply come
and show up with no appointment in
california in some cases
vaccines going unused appointments going
unfilled there are currently 277 million
vaccines
that have been distributed but only 215
million vaccines that have been
administered meaning that states are now
sitting
on 62 million doses with more coming in
on a regular basis now some of those 62
million
are reserved second doses for states
that are still going about it in that
way
but this is not a great sign overall we
right now as of yesterday have about 26
percent of the population
fully vaccinated and 40 percent has
received
at least one dose but the number of
doses
given has declined to just about 3
million doses per day
we had multiple days in the last week
with under
2 million doses per day given which is a
reversal
of the direction that things were going
we can crush this thing we actually have
the tools the resources and the vaccine
supply
to crush this thing if we keep
vaccinating quickly
more quickly but instead vaccination is
slowing down
it may be temporary we know that about
20 percent of the country overall
doesn't want a vaccine overwhelmingly
that group is republicans
as i mentioned 43 of republicans do not
want the vaccine
that's going to hurt our ability to
fight this and the the very people
who from the beginning have said they
want this over or at least they want to
act like it's over well we have a way to
make it be over
and it's called getting vaccinated but
43
of them don't want the vaccine that's
going to hurt our ability to fight this
now one great thing that joe biden
announced yesterday is a tax credit for
employers
to offer paid leave to workers to go and
get vaccinated
we're going to talk about this more on
the bonus show joe biden tweeting quote
i believe everyone who wants a vaccine
should be able to get one
today i announced the tax credit made
possible
by the american rescue plan to help
employers offer paid leave
to workers getting vaccinated you can
learn more at irs.gov
covid as things continue to open
and the odds of needing a vaccine to go
certain places
increases that will probably encourage
more people to get vaccinated but
understand that at this point it's not
oh
how could we maybe end it when could the
end be in sight we could very quickly
get to the pandemic end game and of
course
in the fall we already know uh there
will likely be
boosters for tailored to the variants
but as far as what we can do now to have
a very normal fourth of july just two
and a half months from now
to have a relatively okay memorial day
just five weeks from now
if we keep vaccinating more quickly we
can do it
again look at what's happening in israel
where 56
of the country is fully vaccinated it's
not seventy percent it's not eighty
percent
with fifty six percent fully vaccinated
in israel
cases are so low that it almost looks
like zero on the chart that we are
looking at it's actually about a hundred
and forty cases per day
the pro this is just the perfect example
israel and new jersey have the same size
and the same population you look up
geographic area for israel and new
jersey it's almost the same
you look at population it's almost the
same new jersey has 4 000 cases a day
israel has 140. just
stunning and it's vaccines deaths also
by the way approaching zero
in israel about six per day right now
for comparison new jersey is averaging
about 40 deaths a day
seven times the deaths in new jersey
than in israel
same population same geographical size
and it is vaccines if we can just stay
at 3 million doses a day
we're still going to look pretty good in
four to five weeks if we can get to four
million doses a day
it'll be even faster now if we go back
to two million doses a day or even one
point six one point five million
we give the variance more opportunity
and time to spread
we prolong this let's not do that okay
full eligibility for adults right now in
every state
very very simple just get yourself
vaccinated then figure out whether you
can convince somebody else to do
it last week we had some pretty solid
unemployment numbers or
employment numbers this week we received
pretty shocking and unexpected new
unemployment numbers
new weekly jobless claims announced this
morning
unexpectedly dropped to their lowest
since the start of the pandemic
again for a second week in a row we were
expecting
610 000 people to file new unemployment
claims in the past week we got 547
000 so we came in more than 10
lower than the expected number of
unemployment claims that's negative
from the standpoint of positive i'm
sounding kind of like trump what i mean
is
when you are measuring something bad
people losing jobs
coming in low is good
i tested very positively from the
standpoint of negative okay
for context during the great recession
of the 2000s
the high mark for one week job losses
was 665 thousand we are now below that
number for two weeks in a row
and remember that we are 90 below
what we were seeing in 2020 sometimes 6
million new jobless claims in a single
week we are about 90
below that so that's all pointing in the
right direction now it's not all perfect
there's no reason to pretend it is this
is economic for me it's not political
continuing claims meaning people who
were already unemployed before this week
and are still unemployed that came in
slightly higher than expected at about
3.6 million people that's not great we
want to keep seeing that go down
there is still a generally high level of
unemployment
some states it's really high alaska is
an example
nevada is an example now let's just go
through our
reminder the american right wing
wants us to think things are terrible
and not improving because joe biden is
now president
so they will as they always do when a
democrat is in the white house
say that the normal unemployment rate
doesn't tell us the truth
the truth trademark you need to look
instead
at the u6 the u6 includes people who
are working part-time because they can't
find full-time work
people who are discouraged and they've
stopped looking for work
etc that's fine i i you know that's also
declining
uh the u6 spiked to more than 22 percent
at the start of the pandemic it was down
to 12 point something when trump left
it's now down to 10 point something
percent the u6
is always higher than the u3 but it's
declining as well and that is a very
good thing you know people
people often want to call out one
measure or another
as misleading for political reasons as
if it's some kind of malicious
conspiracy
each of these indicators is designed to
show something different and to tell us
different things
you look at more data points and you
have a deeper understanding of what's
going on
no one data point tells you everything
look at the u3 which is the unemployment
rate that's often talked about on the
news
but also look at the u6 look at wages
look at new claims look at
consumer confidence and inflation which
we see typically through the
consumer price index uh look at the
stock market
it's also a unique situation right now
where there are people who lost jobs
completely due to the pandemic
they're coming back partially now as
businesses start to reopen
many of those those people who are
currently back part-time but they used
to be full-time
they will go back to being full-time
eventually not all
but many will there are some areas in
industries that actually need more
people now
than they did before the pandemic
because there are some industries
on hiring sprees trying to resolve the
supply chain
issues that were exposed by the pandemic
remember that in
march april may of 2020 there are
really examples or anecdotes of
everything for people who want to find
them but the big picture is that things
are improving not surprisingly
and as we said before the biggest
indicators of how things will go in the
coming weeks
are not economic numbers they are
medical numbers when cases trend
down and deaths trend down the economic
indicators are
likely and and reasonably expected to
improve
massachusetts is now down to just 10
coveted deaths a day
that is the lowest number since march of
2020. understand the scope of that
massachusetts now has reduced daily
covet deaths
to a number we haven't seen since 14 13
14 months ago
that is a really good economic indicator
even though it's not an economic
indicator it's actually a medical
indicator so
we know what we have to do we see the
numbers starting to improve
now it's a question of are people going
to get
vaccinated it would not be surprising i
was reading um
a piece from dr dr ashish
shah or jaw i believe his name is from
brown university yesterday
he is saying contagion outdoors is so
low we believe
maybe one in a thousand cases are are
transmitted outdoors
that things are looking good enough that
we could probably do away with any
outdoor masking mandates states that
still have them relatively soon
these these bits of good news are going
to accelerate
the more quickly that cases and deaths
go down which is of course
driven by vaccinations going up let me
know what's going on in your state
are you still wearing masks indoors
outdoors what's going on
um people in the audience living in all
sorts of different situations let me
know on twitter where you can find me at
d
pacman we will take a break and we have
so many things to discuss coming up
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you is high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
we are now at risk of running out of
memberships there has been a run
on memberships at joinpackman.com sort
of like a bank run when everybody wants
to pull their cash out
uh people just going crazy it's almost
like black friday
out there people getting these
memberships you can get yours at
joinpakman.com the best way to
directly support the david pakman show
and of course
discounts we are handing them out with
absolutely no means testing that's the
way i like to do it
take a discount if you want discounts
for everyone
coupon code better21 that will
chop the price of a membership on my
website dramatically
uh we are now approaching
thirty thousand we're like a hundred and
something two hundred away
from thirty thousand subscribers to the
david pakman show
subreddit one of the most subscribed
independent progressive media subreddits
four
shows hosted by left-handed argentinian
jews
among that category we have the biggest
subreddit which is an incredible
achievement a few interesting
discussions i found this morning on the
subreddit
a lot of people trying to sign up for
um not mike pillow mike lindell's
new sort of um a social media platform
frank speech people unable to sign up
user
f men rules said trying to sign up to
mike
pillow twitter wannabe all i get is a
syntax
or server error yeah we talked about
this a little bit
on the bonus show yesterday and i
believe we may be scheduled to talk
about it again
again today uh it's it's hilarious
um i am really taking pleasure in the
complete failure
of the mike pillow frank speech twitter
twitter wannabe
but i've heard from a couple of people
who say they were able to sign up i
don't know how
because the website seems to be
persistently down but a
true comedy of errors taking place with
frankspeach.com i'll even take a look at
it now
see if i can pull up the website uh oh
they've put they've set up ddos
protection
and yeah there's nothing they claim to
have received over two billion requests
in two days
now a lot of it is those a lot of those
two billion are deliberate
repeated attempts to take down the
website um
it's a massive success even though no
one can use it or sign up
okay so that's what's happening on frank
frank speech dot com
user tabasco dan commented
on when people call into the show and
said
what is the point of david taking calls
if it always seems like he wants to
strangle them
unless of course they're from europe
then he wants to see where they've had
lunch
even if the connection sounds like
they're calling from a nuclear submarine
here's what i have to say about this the
fact
that this viewer admits that often the
calls sound like people are calling from
a submarine
vindicates my frustration with the call
quality but
as i've said before most people
we've actually studied this most people
like the calls as an occasional thing
the people that don't are really loud
about it
and sometimes even threaten to cancel
their their subscription all together
when they could just skip that 10-minute
segment on fridays
uh but but um it's a combination of
comedy
and i want to hear from the people i do
want to hear from the people
lastly here is a reddit post
about the youtube recommendations this
is the experience of one viewer who says
youtube recommendations are out of
control
literally on every video on every device
whether on vpn or not
whether signed in or not i go out of my
way to not watch right wingers for any
reason
even to criticize or just out of
curiosity of what fox news propaganda is
blasting no matter the topic
there is always at least one right wing
recommendation
this never used to happen at least not
as much maybe there's an upswing of
right-wing outrage going viral
now that they actually have something to
complain about biden is in power so they
can do the old obama communist routine
seriously i've been recommended two
daily caller videos
when i've been signed into youtube which
i watch david pakman stephen colbert etc
pretty much as far away from the
alt-right trump's as you can get
oh yeah also reddit recommended me
the steven crowder subreddit because it
was similar to this one
is it really that hard for these
algorithms to distinguish what type of
politics
let me ever see any left-wing content
recommended
on youtube to anyone that sentence is a
doozy hold on
let me ever see any left-wing content
recommended on youtube to anyone
anyway the point is as they point out
here conservatives complain about being
censored when these algorithms are
basically affirmative action
for them whether it's deliberate or
accidental doesn't matter
if youtube proudly displays empowering
women
when literally every video has a
feminazi's destroyed video
you know it's complete bs all right uh
the sentiment there
that there's a lot of people being fed a
lot of right wing drivel on youtube
reddit and other platforms
is absolutely true and frequently
i hear from people who say david i only
watch you
and other left-wing shows and youtube
keeps pushing me to
stephen crowder and ben shapiro and all
of this other stuff
it seems to be happening it seems to be
happening join the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
where we have almost 30 000
subreddit subscribers the anti-maskers
are getting even more disgusting if you
can imagine that
at hawthorne elementary school in
beverly hills california
a group of anti-massacres showed up with
signs and flyers
protesting mask rules and they are
accosting
children at school they're accosting
kids telling them among other things
don't wear the mask
the mask smells bad the mask is bad
these are kids doing what their parents
and the school have decided they're
going to do and the protesters show up
and tell them
not to wear masks let's look at one clip
it's visual mostly but you'll also just
from listening get a little bit of a
sense of the atmosphere
[Music]
they are handing out flyers to children
and in this next clip you will actually
hear a a protester
telling a kid i'm sure you hate that
mask i'm sure it smells bad
don't wear it
sometimes you do something that isn't
that fun because it's what the rules are
and because of some greater good i'm the
first one to say
i don't think the outdoor masking has
ever made sense and we're now hearing
from more medical doctors who are
basically saying the same thing
but the indoor masking does make a
difference
and aside from the depraved nature of
telling kids to ignore the health
guidelines
that a school has established don't they
realize that these are children
it is incredibly intimidating for adults
to show up
and talk to kids like this and yell
stuff at them and one of the impressions
i got from watching video of the
protesters
is that there's a real kind of like q
anon
stop the steel type energy or vibe
to these people not just their physical
appearance which is definitely part of
it but just the demeanor everything
about it
and i was looking around at different
commentaries on this and john scott
railton from the university of toronto
tweeted about the exact same thing
saying quote context some may find
interesting a lot of stop the steel
movement energy ditto q anon
has poured into acts and anti-vaccine
agitating
prepare for more of this kind of thing
and of course it's borne out in the
numbers
we know that 43 percent of republicans
don't want to get the vaccine they are
some of the primary drivers of the
anti-vaccine sentiment in addition
we know that both russia and china are
uh
operating on social media to foment
anti-vaccine sentiment and of course as
the 2016
election showed us and other examples um
older right wingers are the most likely
to fall for amplifying
um what i would call destabilizing
propaganda from foreign countries and of
course what better way to destabilize
the u.s
than to encourage people not to do the
one thing that will get us out of the
pandemic which is get
vaccinated now there are lots of
questions about whether this type of
quote protest is protected by the first
amendment
as a general principle it is showing up
there and holding signs that say
no masks or whatever but one might
imagine that when it comes to
starting to yell at children at their
school
when it comes to strangers approaching
kids at school
doesn't it go over into harassment
certainly standing there not blocking
the sidewalk holding an anti-mask sign
absolutely no question about that but
they also appear to sort of be blocking
the sidewalk
they may be interfering with kids
getting in and out of school they're
yelling at children and of course
if anyone tried to shut them down they
would immediately say this is the
government
silencing us taking our first amendment
right
i'm not even suggesting they be shut
down
it's better to tell the kids to ignore
them maybe even set up a way to get kids
in and out of school
without being subject to this i have no
idea if that's possible given the layout
but is there no limit to this where
we're now talking about
yelling at children harassing little
kids about masks
maybe there should be some buffer zone
law like there is with campaigning at
polling places where sure listen you
have a first amendment right
you can campaign for whoever you want
you can hold signs but on election day
you have to be a certain distance from
where people are voting otherwise it
could be considered intimidation
maybe there's something with school
schools as well because we're talking
about kids
i don't know i'm thinking out loud here
they're almost turning the school
into the same type of gauntlet that
anti-abortion activists activists will
try to turn
the entrance area to a medical clinic
for women considering an abortion
it's it's a similar type of harassment
except
more vile because these are children
who are going by what their parents and
school officials
are saying are going to be the rules as
a country
when you see video of
anti masters yelling at children
and harassing kids at school that
doesn't bode well for the united states
as a country when you see that that's a
red flag that things may be going in a
very bad direction
um let me know your thoughts we're going
to have more coverage of this on our
instagram page you can find
the david pakman show on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram at
david.pakman
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
damon centola who's a professor of
communication
sociology and engineering at the
university of pennsylvania
also author of the book change how to
make big things happen
damon i have to ask you is trump right
that at u-pen they just can't stop
talking about him is that really what
everybody's fixated on there that he
went
to to upenn well like most of the things
donald trump says
it you know has very little bearing on
the truth
there are very few conversations about
him most of what we talk about is how to
fix the policies
right in place well i i want to to
really dive into the meat of this book
because i find the topic very
interesting which is what
what works to achieve social change and
what does not work and we sort of have a
bit of an example from the last year
when it comes to influencers and
vaccination there was the idea
relatively early
that getting so-called influencers
to just show themselves being vaccinated
or say it's a good idea to get
vaccinated that through their status
alone
this would convince lots of people to
get vaccinated
good strategy bad strategy based on your
research
yeah i mean the background here is that
the notion of influencers or
highly connected people as the key to
social change
really dates back to the 1940s um
there's sort of
nearly a century of research on this um
and the way that we think about it is
that
people who are really disproportionately
connected and so
obviously most of us know things that on
social media like that kim kardashian
characters right who are
massively connected and i think that we
have this intuition that comes from
marketing
um that companies figured out very early
on which is that someone who's so
massively connected could be really
effective for
um spreading things like new brands of
coconut water or new teeth whitening
creams right
um and then there was this sort of
generalization
and there were a series of popular books
written
around 2000 that kind of said well look
if
virus is spread this way and information
spreads this way
it seems like everything should spread
this way right um every kind of
initiative every kind of
campaign every political movement or
social change effort should
try to make use of influencers um and
there's something really appealing about
that
which is that you know it kind of solves
a very hard problem
very hard problem is how do you get lots
of people to change their beliefs
or their behavior um vaccination is one
where
there's obviously a lot of hesitancy a
lot of uncertainty
you know reasons why people would resist
it and so if we could just find the key
people
to initiate a change process you know we
would have
a lot of very hard problems solved very
quickly right
the problem with that view is that it
turns out that the logic of disease
spreading the logic of information
spreading
doesn't generalize to contagious
behaviors
that really are disruptive or that go
against the existing social norms that
challenge the way that we're thinking
and acting and require
additional more additional effort or
additional cost
and that's really the crux of my work is
showing that
the core intuition about influencers
really only works
for simple things and
you know the idea of the influencer has
come from epidemiology
it's come from the idea of like a super
spreader someone who gets sick they talk
to a lot of people
then a lot of people get sick
so interestingly i mean i like the
example of you talked about coconut
water
it sounds like part of this is coconut
water is not something that too many
people
that i know at least feel very strongly
about they may not
feel very strongly one way or the other
and that's very different than something
like for example vaccine hesitancy and
so
what might work with something
relatively innocuous like coconut water
would not necessarily work with
something like vaccination
yeah and the core scientific distinction
here is between what's called simple
contagion and complex contagion
um and this is the big breakthrough
right so the science of contagion
20 years ago looked very different than
us today we've had lots of new methods
but also lots of new theoretical
breakthroughs and that's kind of what
this
book is about and what these insights
are about is that when we look at the
spread of simple contagions
which basically means information and
disease
it tends to be the case that all you
need is exposure to
one infected or activated person to
transmit it
right someone tells you a new piece of
information you don't really look around
to say how many other people knew this
piece of information
you say oh look at me i found this out
first and then you can repeat it
there's actually a certain cachet then
to the novelty information
um the same is true with the copic 19
virus
if no one you know is sick it doesn't
really matter all you need is contact
with one sick person
to transmit the disease right right so
if you have an influencer is highly
connected they can spread to a lot of
people
the point you're making is that look
there's lots of behaviors that aren't
like that that just because we come into
contact with them
doesn't mean we adopt them in fact we
look really carefully at who that person
is maybe that person is different from
us you know we belong to one political
party they belong to a different one
we have you know we have one group of
social friends they have very different
friends
and as a result of those differences and
the sort of social factors that we
really perceive without even thinking
about it
we evaluate their behavior maybe reject
it and say oh that's kind of deviant or
i disagree with that the people in my
social group aren't doing that
and so mere exposure isn't enough for
transmission
yeah it actually seems like there's some
research including from the field of
behavioral economics and also social
psychology that
certain types of beliefs uh beliefs that
are maybe in certain buckets
that might include religious beliefs
political beliefs etc
sometimes regularly coming into contact
with with a different
perspective will make you kind of plant
your feet
where you are if you identify that those
with a different view are from an
out group that is not your group yeah
and that's there's it even gets worse
it's not just planning your feed it's
actually you retreat back into your
you kind of double down on your position
there's term to term biased assimilation
just means
we assimilate new information in kind of
a biased way we're the bias of our group
helps us determine what we believe and
we can actually
become even more entrenched in our
beliefs as a result of confronting
conflicting ideas but the punchline here
is this
this discovery of complex contagion that
there's this whole
class of things that we deeply care
about right everything from disruptive
products to new political initiatives to
initiatives for vaccination um are
uh difficult to adopt and they spread
through networks in a different way
and it means that all of our classic um
theories intuitions and strategies from
epidemiology and informational marketing
not only don't work but they can like
backfire um in in sort of the way you
described right they can backfire in the
sense that they can
make people uh more entrenched in a
position as opposed to helping loosen
their biases or weaken their biases but
also there's
lots of really sort of famous cases of
using influencers to advertise a product
and making the product
less appealing because of the way that
the influencers were so different from
everybody else
what are some examples of that the most
conspicuous one is that
is google plus and google glass right a
lot of us remember google glass
um and google used the kind of
influencer strategy they got high
profile
you know wealthy techy people in the san
francisco bay area you know cutting edge
people who are on the sort of forefront
of socio-technical sophistication to
start wearing glass
and the idea was this was supposed to
create aspiration we're all supposed to
want to be like the influencer which is
the influencer model right
um and they go out to you know
restaurants and coffee shops and they
said
i'm wearing their fancy eyewear so
everyone knows it's there right so lots
of exposure
what wound up happening was this
tremendous cultural backlash
um and everyone remembers that the term
was sort of invented
by people who encountered this the term
glasshole
right for someone who would actually
wear it and that was to distinguish
people who were part of that sort of
influencer cutting edge
from the rest of us and that was the
sort of the crux of their failures they
didn't take into account that most
people have social norms
that would cause them to reject this
idea norms about surveillance and public
norms about like just decorum and social
interactions the idea that you'd be
browsing the web while talking to
someone
right people were genuinely offended by
this technology
and so this is an instance where just
trying to kind of force it on a
population
by going through the influencers didn't
take into account the fact that the
population
is people with beliefs and norms and
there you know if they don't like it and
they don't like the way that this is
being introduced
it's actually going to be something
that's viewed in a very negative way so
this not only
caused the product line to be um stopped
entirely
but it actually hurt the reputation of
the company so that's like that's a
colossal backfire
yeah um and so it's a good example of
the
sort of the issue when it comes to
change and the issue is social norms the
issue is you have to think about
who the people are and what their
beliefs are and then how those beliefs
could change
and this is kind of a famous thing in uh
public health that public health
initiatives for decades have faced this
challenge
from trying to spread hiv prevention
technologies to now
trying to spread face masks and then
trying to spread uh vaccination
and most of the initial cases were you
know in sub-saharan africa and we had a
lot of data about failures
of massive efforts by the the um cdc and
the nih to
um change people's behavior about hiv
prevention and
their kind of hair pulling experiences
of realizing just how bad
their messaging strategies based on
influencers and based on stickiness and
based on viral messaging
how badly it backfired where no one
would actually wind up using a
technology that was free
easy to use and available like all the
things that are supposed to make us
wanted
yeah i remember some examples from the
2014 ebola situation
where uh western doctors were sent
into the the most at risk and affected
countries
to talk about how this spreads and it
was just completely rejected because
they were the wrong messengers it didn't
matter what they were going to say they
were just not the right messengers for
that community
right it was it was ultimately ebola was
viewed as a
white disease because you had so many
white physicians
in these situations giving advice to
um to locals that really contradicted
social local religious norms like
there was one in particular like what's
called standing near the hill which is
exactly what it sounds like you actually
physically locate yourself and you're a
sick person and it's it's kind of a
spiritual commitment to them
but of course ebola is insanely
contagious
and so what they wanted to do is to
separate people from people who had like
open wounds and
and um were you know highly infectious
and so
uh the that was viewed as a kind of uh
cultural profanity
and and it sort of fell along race lines
and along culture lines
and that again created a kind of
distance you know that physicians were
this authority figure
telling people what to do and
populations resisted
and to bring it back to the point of you
know what complex contagions mean for us
now
this is exactly what's happening with uh
vaccination
right right we're getting a lot of
medical experts the kind of authority
figures you know high profile people
telling people what to do and you're
getting populations kind of galvanizing
you know experiencing solidarity around
their vaccination and resistance
um and so the whole strategy in the book
which the book was published before all
this happened right but it actually
is completely relevant to these
challenges because the whole strategy in
the book
is about when influencers fail
how to engage social networks in a way
that can shift social norms and make
people more receptive to new ideas
um and so there's the story after story
i talk about black lives matter i talk
about
the civil rights movement i talk about
the berlin wall protests all these
different
sort of examples of how these social
change initiatives succeeded
actually their technology examples like
facebook and twitter but
the punch line is that the key to social
change is
kind of the last place you would think
to look it's actually out in the sort of
margins
of the social network it's sort of the
outer edges the people who are regular
folks
and what we're looking for here isn't
special people which has been the model
for a very long time
influencers are somehow different from
the rest of us and that's what makes
them the key
change we're actually looking for are
these special locations
in the network these sort of patterns in
the geometry of our social connectedness
and when we find those which are
actually fairly easy to find
we can actually identify locations where
it's fairly
easy and practical to initiate a kind of
a critical mass dynamic where we kind of
grow support for a new movement that
might challenge what people believe but
because
there's reinforcement among friends of
friends and because it's sort of
in a locally clustered group they can
sort of
shift away from whatever the status quo
is and then once that critical mass
takes hold basically then you get a
cascade process where it kind of flows
through the rest of the network
and once a critical mass becomes large
enough this is where we see tipping
points happen
right and this is kind of what we saw
with black lives matter black lives
matter was this marginal fringe movement
that took hold
just regular people in communities and
then once it got large enough
you saw you know white suburban
housewives marching
with you know black inner city youth for
black lives matter which is something
that no one could have anticipated
you know five years earlier right and so
it's a real change in like
who's part of this process and all of a
sudden everyone was part of this process
and that's when we see a tipping point
that's exactly what we see
yeah anecdotally we've we've seen that
even just like with the growth of you
take any one of our platforms like
youtube where there seems to be this
geometric s
curve that happens where initially the
amount of work required for a little bit
of growth is huge like our first
thousand subscribers our first ten
thousand subscribers
you then get enough critical mass where
maybe you get a tipping point where you
quickly get to
you know a hundred or two hundred
thousand and then there's a period where
it slows down again and then you get
sort of to the next tipping point
is that typical of the types of
movements you
study as well yeah it's typical of
almost
every large-scale growth curve this was
in the back in the 60s
1969 1970 there's this famous thing was
called the bass curve
and this was he was just describing like
consumer electronics durable goods
like refrigerators um or you know like
televisions and like what those growth
curves look like
um but what wasn't explained was the
social mechanics that
allowed that growth curve to happen and
most importantly that help that elbow in
the curve where you go from
slow glow growth into that kind of like
rapidly accelerating like exponential
growth you know week after week what's
happening at that elbow
and that was just unexplained it was
like well it took off
but like okay so what is that and there
are a lot of things that start to grow
slowly and then peter out
so what's the difference between those
two things and that's where my book sort
of answers that question
says well plenty of things start to grow
but they never get into the networks in
the right way and so they kind of peter
out
but if you get into networks in the
right way when you start to grow
you actually build oh that was one of my
mics you actually build
an earphone that uh yeah i said you
build an earphone you can take that out
you actually you actually build a um
uh a kind of contagion process built
within the infrastructure of the social
network right
that then basically forms the basis of
the critical mass and that is the
difference between the cases where you
get that elbow up and the pace in the
cases where you just kind of peter out
um and that's kind of the powerful
lesson is that that's something we can
control
we can do experiments on and more
importantly we can develop policy around
that makes a ton of sense and uh we've
been we've been speaking about
much of what is in damon sintolo's book
change
how to make big things happen he
is a professor in a number of
disciplines at the university of
pennsylvania
damon so great speaking to you today
absolutely thank you
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what
pat does all day very very concerning to
a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account
at david pakman show you might remember
that in advance of the derek chauvin
verdict which we got
earlier this week the jury
was sequestered but before the jury was
sequestered maxine waters made some
comments that are the subject of
significant controversy which we already
talked about democratic congresswoman
from california
after the jury was sequestered president
biden gave his opinion
about the case and it ended up being
that there were
three guilty verdicts there were there
was no violence afterwards
maybe there would have been violence had
there been an acquittal maybe not we
don't know it didn't happen
that's what we know when we're operating
in terms of what actually took place
donald trump's former secretary press
secretary uh press secretary kelly
mcinanni
criticized joe biden for commenting
before the verdict but
after the jury was sequestered saying
that presidents should not
inflame tensions this is
beyond parody as the former press
secretary
of the insider in chief donald trump of
course inciting a violent
riotous insurrection on january 6th of
this year
these people i mean satire is you could
not possibly parody what they are saying
let's take a look at the video
if you are allergic to hypocrisy if you
have an aversion to cringe
i would skip the next 36 seconds of
video we heard judge cahill go on to
caution elected officials and say i urge
you not to weigh in
just hours before or half a day before
the president himself weighs in look i'm
glad he at least waited until the jury
was sequestered
but i think that the country is such a
tender box right now especially
minneapolis there's so much hurt
so much pain and i think it's the role
of the president of the united states
to stay back to not inflame the tensions
i'd like that he called the family of
george floyd president trump
did too but it's such a tinderbox moment
and i think he should have just reserved
comment and said he's praying for the
family as we all are can you
imagine a more hypocritical statement
it isn't merely that donald trump
incited a riot on january 6th
he talked about sending in the military
during the george floyd protest
back in the summer of 2020 to rough
people up people were protesting
the very thing which trump reacted by
threatening to do more of
and on and on and on with other examples
it's just too much
it's too pathetic and by the way it's
not just kaylee mcinanny
uh uh whose former boss was doing it
kaylee mcinanni herself participated in
fanning the flames
from november through january by ginning
up
anger over a supposedly stolen election
which
set the tone for the january sixth riots
trump would not have been able to incite
the january sixth riots
if there had been silence about a
supposedly stolen election and dominion
and massive dumps and all of this
different stuff
from november to january the whole
environment from november to january and
the you know mike pillow
on newsmax talking about it and sydney
powell and rudy giuliani and all these
other people
you needed that in order to get to
january 6th when trump said let's go to
the capitol and that's exactly what they
did and kaylee mcinanny participated in
that as well
she says biden shouldn't inflame
tensions
when trump was the guy who said when the
looting starts the shooting starts
and said oh they're protesting police
brutality i'm going to send in the
military
to rough them up and can stop uh the
the protest so yes this is the painful
hypocrisy we've seen for years now from
these people
yes this is kaylee mcinanni trying to be
interesting
and relevant and failing to do that and
yes this is the
type of stuff that contributed to
why things are the way they are right
now
i think kaylee probably realizes
the hypocrisy of what she's saying
kaylee mcinanni
is completely amoral but she's not
actually stupid but deliberately or not
whether she knows she's lying or not and
i think she knows she is
she's participating in the attempt to
sort of rewrite history
about what took place on january 6th
about what the trump presidency was
and also on the george floyd situation
and you have to remember that the
to the modern american right wing the
political right wing in the united
states right now
the need for any kind of consistency
or intellectual honesty is for losers
and
suckers to use one of donald trump's
phrases the only thing that matters to
them
is that they own the libs that they
destroy their political enemies no
matter how they do it
and this is why to some degree we have
to keep talking about
trump and the cronies from the
administration because
if we don't trump himself and people
like kaylee mcinanny will rehabilitate
donald trump's image by saying things
like
he had the greatest economy ever for
three years they won't talk about year
four
or covet they'll not talk about january
6th
they'll not talk about his failed
response to the coronavirus that that'll
basically be it
and the cult of personality around
donald trump on social media
will amplify only that message it's
basically gaslighting
at the individual incident level like
kaylee mcinannion fox says
presidents shouldn't inflame tensions
but then you remember
oh it's part of the bigger picture of an
effort to rewrite history
about donald trump so whatever is in
kaylie's mind
you know at minimum even if she knows
that she's being a hypocritical liar
she's at least indifferent to the
blatant double standard of her words
publicly and her former boss's actions
and that's already bad enough uh they
will continue to do this they've already
done it if you go
listen we looked at the interviews um i
think it was late last week
with uh or maybe early last week at that
trump event in florida
where trump supporters were interviewed
about
january 6th and they now belie i think
they have actually fallen for it they're
not just saying it they have fallen for
it wasn't really trump supporters it was
antifa
in disguise uh and anyway they were
peaceful which conflicts it's like wait
a second
were they peaceful trump protesters or
were they not really trump protesters
somehow it's both it's they were
peaceful trump protesters
and they were also antifa whatever
they've fallen for it and we can't allow
it to become the predominant narrative
because otherwise that's how you end up
with george w bush now
being seen as just this friendly old man
rather than
uh the disastrous war criminal that he
actually was so let's uh
we're going to stay on it that's for
sure this next story requires
some explanation but it's pretty
fascinating
a couple of days ago tucker carlson fox
news propagandist
ran a kind of strange out-of-place
commentary on his show
where he vaguely referred to his college
yearbooks and people like jeff bezos
looking for dirt
on tucker carlson and it was weird
because it was just out of context it
seemed to have nothing to do with what
was going on on tucker's show
and it raised the question of whether
tucker carlson was trying to get ahead
of a maybe embarrassing or
problematic story so let's start by
taking a look at that this is the clip
from a couple of nights ago just kind of
out of nowhere we don't know what this
was about
a quick piece of news from the world of
big tech we spent the day hearing from
quite a few old college classmates in
some cases people we've been out of
touch with for 30 years
it was nice but here was the occasion
for it jeff
bezos had one of his minions a mentally
unbalanced middle-aged man called eric
wempel
pull our dusty college yearbook and call
around to see if we've done anything
naughty at the age of 19. that sounds
like fun
let us know if you hear any good stories
but before bezos drops any more of his
billions on opposition research he
should know that it will not affect
any election outcome this is a news show
it's not a political campaign
no one here is running for anything or
plans to on the other hand if jeff bezos
wants to come over to reminisce about
1987 on this show
he's always welcome anytime sort of a
strange
story in a vacuum but then yesterday
it all starts to become much clearer an
image purporting to be tucker carlson's
college yearbook entry
from trinity college in 1991.
mentions that tucker was part of a
number of groups including
the christian fellowship okay the jesse
helms
foundation uh oh and something called
the dan
white society now for those wondering
whether this is even a real image
trinity college has confirmed that this
is their real 1991 yearbook
tucker's entry is on page 186 there is
no question about it being
real and this started to raise some
questions because
the dan white society references
dan white dan white was a guy who
killed san francisco mayor george
mascone
and supervisor harvey milk california's
first
openly gay elected official in 1978
dan white was a horrible person a
disgustingly violent homophobic
person and so when you look at tucker's
yearbook
and it says dan white society that's
starting to look not so good
and then our longtime friend jeremy
hooper
did some more research into this and
found a 1990 op-ed
by tucker carlson in his college
newspaper where he calls homosexuality
quote unnatural
and unhealthy and it is signed
tsm carlson and indeed jeremy confirmed
that tucker carlson is the only possible
student
with those initials at that time it also
appears as jeremy hooper points out on
twitter
that this is the only thing tucker ever
wrote in the newspaper meaning it's not
that tucker was a regular columnist
and it just so happened that one day he
wrote about
unnatural gay people he went out of his
way
to write one column one time about
his displeasure with the fact that gay
people
exist now to me this is less about
whether tucker carlson was homophobic in
1990 or 1991
as a sort of potential disqualifier for
tucker to do
whatever today first of all there's tons
of people that are homophobic
secondly i don't think being homophobic
is considered a problem for fox news
host that may even
it may be a feature more than it is a
bug and third
most importantly in theory tucker's
views
may have changed over the last 30 years
i have views that are different today
than they were 30 years ago
and much like i would say about anyone
if these were tucker's views 30 years
ago and they appear to be
it doesn't necessarily tell us how his
views are today many of
my views have changed although i was
never anti-gay it's more about the
strange nature of
how tucker ended up getting into this
story earlier this week
doing this bizarre proactive segment to
attack
jeff bezos and to say people are
looking for dirt it's just all very
strange
now that being said yeah tucker's heroes
in college were really disturbing it's
not just
that he of the three groups he mentions
one
seems to be an adoration of the guy who
killed harvey milk for being gay
that's horrifying he also shouts out
jesse helms jesse helms used to be a
senator
who opposed the civil rights act opposed
the voting rights act called the civil
rights act
dangerous and on and on if these were
tucker's heroes then
i'd be curious as to who his heroes are
today it's really horrible stuff
i don't expect much more to come of it
you know anybody
oh he should be fired from fox news yeah
right even if fox news doesn't see this
as a feature
um it's not going to cause a problem for
tucker on fox news but a very strange
story and watching it develop it
watching it develop over the week even
stranger with the proactive oh people
are calling around looking for dirt on
me
really weird let me know what you make
of it if you want to call into the show
but you want to leave me a message as
opposed to talk to me live
you can call literally any time of day
3am as many people call in
2pm whenever you can call 219
to davidp and you can leave a voicemail
here's a voicemail about um
in i guess we would call them
inter-political
relationships relationships between left
and right wingers
take a listen to this hey david quick
question
do you think you could date or marry
a good faith conservative not one of
these cuid on people
um do you think because i know bill
maher talked about this on his chair one
time
about i can't think of the couple but
one of them was a republican strategist
and the husband was a liberal strategist
democratic strategist
but from what i understand they were
both you know reasonable people they
weren't you know
one of them wasn't crazy right-wing
lunatic or crazy loved one
do you think you could date a pretty
much middle-of-the-road
reasonable um intelligent
conservative or or now yeah so listen um
i this is this is a good question
uh i i once did date a conservative
sort of but at the time i didn't know
she was a conservative at the time she
really wasn't a conservative her family
was and
politics just weren't on my radar i
think had that relationship
lasted um it would not have worked
because it was pretty wacky brand of
conservatism but but beyond that you
know
as an adult it's hard to imagine i mean
listen i think if if you want to come up
with a sort of uh
conservative who like thinks taxes
should be lower than i think they should
be
and doesn't think medicare for all is
the right way to arrange health care and
can sort of like reasonably defend it
but they're not
homophobic or anti-abortion i mean i
think that a lot of the social issues
would be tougher because
in a um in a social context that starts
to become
weird and awkward and i would also
question
a lot of the social things like you you
can think taxes should be lower than i
think they should be
but more or less have a moral framework
that is in line with mine
it's hard for me to imagine someone
who's homophobic
anti-abortion extremely religious
and um you know thinks
creationism should be taught in science
class who otherwise
is going to share my values in a way
that wouldn't be a problem so i i guess
what i'm saying is
if the differences are economic to some
degree
or or something like that it seems like
that would not be a problem relationship
wise but
but going beyond that i think would be
extremely difficult
we have a great bonus show for you today
manhattan
will stop prosecuting prostitution and
will dismiss cases dating back decades
very interesting decision made there
a governor kay ivey of alabama has
signed a bill
allowing college athletes to monetize
their name image and likeness very
interesting in terms of what it will do
uh in a number of different ways for
athletes in alabama
and joe biden as i mentioned earlier is
calling for every employee to get paid
leave for vaccinations and in fact
um putting in place a tax credit for
employers
to allow employees to get paid
to be paid have paid leave i think
better said
to go and get vaccinated will this move
the needle we'll talk about that
and more on the bonus show how do you
get access to the bonus show
two ways number one become a member at
joinpacman.com
easy quick you'll be listening or
watching listening to or watching the
bonus show in under a minute
second option patreon
become a patron at patreon.com
slash davidpakmanshow i will see you
then
you